- Hello, and welcome to
EdTalks with Khan Academy.
I'm Kristen DiCerbo, the
Chief Learning Officer
at Khan Academy.
And today I am looking forward to talking
with Dr. Thomas Guskey about
many things learning related,
but particularly grades and
grading and reporting systems.
Before we get started,
I have a couple things
to remind you of.
First, Khan Academy is a
non-profit organization,
and we are able to do our
work, thanks to donations
from folks like you.
If you go to khanacademy.org/donate,
you can help us be able to continue
to do the work that we do.
Thank you for doing that.
Second, I wanna recognize
some of our corporate sponsors
who have particularly helped
us in the COVID 19 crisis,
including AT and T,
General Motors and Fastly.
And finally, if you want
to hear this conversation
or other conversations
that Sal or I have had
with folks in the education
industry or outside,
talking about education related things,
you can find us on your podcast
app at Homeroom with Sal,
The podcast.
So with that, I am glad to
welcome Dr. Thomas Guskey.
He has written over 25
award-winning books,
but his latest is Get Set, Go.
Creating Successful Grading
and Reporting Systems.
So we'll be talking about that.
He's also the Professor Emeritus
in the College of Education
at the University of Kentucky,
where he served as Department Chair,
Head of the Educational
Psychology Area Committee
and President of the Faculty Council.
He began his career in education
as a middle school teacher
and earned his doctorate at
the University of Chicago
under the direction of
Professor Benjamin Bloom,
and served as an administrator
in Chicago Public Schools
before becoming the first director
of the Center for the Improvement
of Teaching and Learning
at National Research Center.
So welcome.
Thank you for joining us today.
- Thank you, Kristen.
I've been a long admirer of
the work at the Khan Academy.
So this is quite an honor for me.
Thank you.
- Oh, it is an honor for us to have you.
I'd like to get started
in talking to folks
a little bit about their career paths.
So as you think about how you ended up
being a professor and researcher,
studying the things you
study, how did you get there?
What did you say when you were a kid
that what you wanted
to be when you grew up
and how did that evolve?
- Well, I had a very different career path
than most people in education.
My undergraduate major in college
was actually physics and
electrical engineering,
but I graduated from college
with my degree in that area
to discover that I have no
talent in that field at all,
which was a terrible
disappointment to my father,
who is an engineer.
And I was at a party one
night, which I did a lot
at that time, talking
to a friend who told me
about a teaching job.
He had been looking for a teaching job
and he was at private school,
a middle school where they needed
a seventh and eighth grade math teacher
who would also coach.
And this just happened to
be the third week of August.
My father always claimed
that the only reason
I was hired is I passed a mirror test.
They put a mirror under my nose, it fogged
and so I got the job.
But I started teaching middle school
and I just fell in love with it.
I know a lot of people
struggle with that age
of children, but I just
thought they were terrific.
So as a continuency of me being hired,
I had to gain my certification.
So I began taking education classes
then I gained my certification.
And then after several years, decided
that I really wanted to
go back to graduate school
to learn how to become a better teacher.
So I began in Boston and then ended up
at the University of
Chicago, where my chair,
my advisor and the chair of my Doctoral
Dissertation Committee was Benjamin Bloom.
So it was from that, that
I really became interested
in the whole area of educational
measurements and valuation,
learned about the taxonomy, learned about
instruction and mastery learning
and then began working with
Chicago Public Schools.
Did that for several years
and decided after that,
I really wanted to go into
a university position.
So, accepted a position here
at the University of Kentucky
in the department of Educational
School and Counseling Psychology
and where I spent most
of my academic career.
- Fantastic.
So as I alluded to, you
have written a lot of books
and articles,
an impressive library.
So if you had to pick out some
of the areas that you think
that you say, hey, I have a
lot to say about this topic.
What are some of those
areas that you feel like
are important to, that you
have some important things
to talk about?
- Right.
Well, my very first book was on
Implementing Mastery Learning,
and this was an extension
of what I had learned
with Benjamin Bloom.
He was the person who
developed the whole concept
of mastery learning.
And then when I began working
with Chicago Public Schools,
we were leading a team of
people there really to implement
Bloom's ideas into the public
school system in Chicago.
So that was really my first interest,
the instructional programs and
the idea of using assessments
as learning tools.
But my dissertation was
actually in the area of change,
and teacher change in particular.
So that led me into a
profound interest in,
not only the change process,
but teacher learning
and professional learning experiences
for teachers.
So developed a book,
developed an evaluation model
for professional learning, looking at
how we can translate professional
learning for educators
into learning for students.
Then that, from that
got me interested in
sort of using assessments
as learning tools as we had
through mastery learning.
That took in the area of assessment.
And then when we gather that information,
we have to report it and communicate it
to parents and to families.
And that brought me into
the area of grading.
And that's really what
I've been focusing on
for the last several
years of grading issues
and how to really enhance that,
understanding what we know
about the grading process and
then how we can improve it
to enhance the communication
between schools and homes.
- That totally makes sense.
And I see how things built on each other
to get to where you are today.
So before we get to the grading piece,
I'd love to talk a little bit
more about mastery learning
since it is, also at Khan
Academy, a foundational piece
in terms of how we think about it.
So for those who are
watching, who don't know,
Dr. Benjamin Bloom is
considered one of the pioneers,
and then Dr. Guskey has
taken many of those lessons
and applied them and shared
them with the world as well.
How do you, when you went
in and were first talking
to teachers, or even now, when
you're talking to teachers
who are just learning
about mastery learning,
how do you introduce
it to them in terms of
what are the main, the key points
and the key elements of it?
- Well, I always introduce
mastery learning to teachers
as a way to solve the two biggest problems
that teachers face.
The first being, the whole
notion of motivation.
How do I motivate students to learn things
that they may not consider
important in their lives
or don't seem as relevant?
And the idea is that the key to motivation
and what we know seems
to be the foundation
of building motivation is success.
I mean, students persist in activities
which they're successful
and they avoid with passion,
those things in which
they're not successful
or believe they cannot be.
I mean, I always use the
example of video games.
I mean, the biggest selling
video game of all time
is Pac-Man.
I mean, nothing has ever outsold Pac-Man.
It's like a 17, $18 billion industry.
And the purpose of Pac-Man is
basically to gobble up dots.
Now, what makes that interesting?
What makes that relevant
to anybody's life?
Nothing.
And as people say, well,
maybe it's behavioral.
Maybe it's based on the rewards you get,
but that's not true.
I mean, in Pac-Man, what do you get
if you go up all the dots?
You get more dots.
That's a great world.
I mean, that's like saying,
look, do these 10 problems,
I'll give you 10 more to do.
But what Pac-Man did is it showed people
that they could be successful at this task
and capitalized in that success.
Every time they'd improve,
make the challenge
a little bit greater and
show you could succeed it.
So that's the same that what
we have to carry through
in education, we have to find ways
we can help students succeed
and see that they can be
successful as learners.
But that ties to the second major problem.
And that problem is the
diversity the teachers face
in group based instruction.
I mean, it would be great to think about
individualized instruction of programs,
but we'll never be able to get
to a situation in our country
where we have a class size of one.
It's always going to be group based.
And because of that
diversity in, there is,
no matter what approach a teacher chooses,
it works for some, it
doesn't work for others.
And so teachers have to
find a way to provide
for the diversity of needs
in a group based environment.
And those are exactly the
two conditions under which
Benjamin Bloom developed the
ideas of mastery learning.
What could we do in a
group based environment
to help more students learn
excellently the things we have
to teach and gain the
many positive benefits
of that success.
So I think, it's approached
as a way of solving
those two critical
problems that teachers face
and giving them a solution to an issue
with which they've always been familiar
and probably have always struggled.
- I continue to hear those as probably
the two biggest questions
that we get from teachers.
How do I help differentiate
for all the different levels
I have in my class and how
do I motivate students?
So that absolutely makes
sense in terms of the problems
to be solved and where those
were and that it continues to,
over years, that it continues
to be some of the issues
that teachers face.
When you were first starting,
so, don't wanna make you feel old,
but you've been doing this for a while.
- Yes, that's true.
- What were some of the conditions then
and how do you see things
either changing or the same
in the world, in the
school environments now?
- Well, it certainly has changed a lot.
I mean, I have the advantage
of, now with social media,
many of my former students,
middle school students
are now my friends on
Facebook and they write to me
about their lives and what's going on.
And the positive ways in
which education has changed,
especially through the use of technology,
it's just remarkable the things
that we're able to do today,
but the social conditions
are really different.
But teachers are, I think,
very sensitive to that
and aware of the things that
our students bring to school
and how we have to help them
use school as an environment
in which they can feel safe.
And in the safety of that environment,
really become successful in learning.
And I think that's where Benjamin Bloom,
where they made a remarkable difference.
And he said that, learning in
any subject area is infinite,
and there's no limit to what you can learn
in any subject area at all,
but a curriculum is finite.
And when we identify a
curriculum, what we do,
is we take that entire domain of learning
in any academic discipline
or subject area,
and we specify these
are the things we think
all students should be
able to learn really well.
Then, once we do that,
our job as educators
becomes doing everything within our power
to ensure that all students, not just some
but really all, learn that excellently.
And so where Bloom really
differed in his orientation
compared to others, is that at that time
when he developed these
ideas and the late 1960s
and early 1970s, people were talking about
equality of educational opportunity
and doing things to
make sure that all kids
had similar opportunities
when they entered school.
And Bloom saw that as just
an impossible sort of thing
that no matter what we did, our
society was going to dictate
that kids would come to
school dramatically different.
And what we needed to do was
not concern ourselves so much
with the quality of
opportunity, but equity
in terms of the outcomes
and what could we do
to ensure that all students,
regardless of the conditions
they brought with them to school,
were able to learn excellently.
And so they would master that curriculum,
gain the benefits of success
and be able to carry that over
to what they then would
have in their lives.
- That absolutely makes sense
as we think about equity
and equality and those
are certainly themes
that we're seeing playing
out in schools today,
as salient as they were then,
I think they continue to be.
As we think about that equality,
I know one of the struggles
that teachers have in
classrooms is thinking about,
when students have those
gaps that need to be filled
in their foundational knowledge.
And they also have the pressure,
teachers have the pressure
of meeting those grade level standards.
And I have to cover all
this material this year.
How do you help teachers
think about that tension?
- Well, I think one of the
things that I try to emphasize
in my work is that we're never
going to be able to overcome
all those gaps that students
might have when they come in.
And I think it's really a
folly to try to look back
and think about all that
they might have missed.
What's much more
productive is to look ahead
and with each learning
unit, try to identify
the maybe two or three things
that students need to have
in order to succeed in this next unit.
They don't, you're not going to remedy
like three years of learning deficits
in the first six months of school.
But what you can do is look ahead
to that first instructional unit and say,
in order for the students
to really be successful,
to start at a level playing field,
here are the two or three things
they really need to learn.
These are the things
they really need to have.
This would establish a baseline for them.
This would be the prerequisite for it.
And then what we do is we
teach those two or three things
to a level of mastery, and then,
everybody's starting on
that level playing field.
And when you get everybody starting
in a level playing field,
then you can guarantee
success in that first unit.
And typically, success in the first unit
is prerequisite for
success in the second unit.
Although in the second
unit, you might again,
look ahead and identify
if there were any things
that I would expect students
to know and be able to do
to really succeed in this one.
And it could take a little bit of time.
And what we find is that,
if teachers can do that,
to look ahead, rather than looking back
and take a little bit of time
at the beginning of
every instructional unit
to really emphasize those prerequisites.
Not only does it mean their
instruction can increase
in its pace later, but it gives kids
the necessary preconditions for success.
So it's the idea that
instead of remedying promise
in the past, we look
ahead to what kids need
and then provide that in a
really structured environment
and then be able to build
on that as we go along.
- All right.
I rarely, I don't like
to use these (indistinct)
Khan Academy things, but I
just wanted to run this by you.
So we have what we call get
ready for grade level courses.
Which essentially your sixth,
you have your sixth grade course.
Say you have a unit on decimals,
the get ready for course,
has the get ready for decimals unit,
which has those two or three prerequisites
that you need to do decimals.
And that we want teachers
to use in that way
and leaving them in.
So we have read what you're suggesting
and taken that in and built on that.
So--
- Kristen,
it's one of the reasons
I'm such an admirer
of the Khan Academy work because
it's so thoughtfully structured and you do
such a very good job of
building on exactly those ideas.
Those get ready things are
just absolutely on target
and just precisely what
we would need to do
to ensure that higher level
success for our students.
- Yeah.
Always excited to hear folks saying,
talking about the things and I can say,
yes, we're trying to do that.
- It was so thoughtful in design.
- Absolutely.
Let's move into talking a
little bit about grading
and where you've been writing
and thinking about grades
and grading.
What would you say are the big factors
in effective and accurate grading?
- Well, we actually did a
very large project in 2016
where the American Educational
Research Association
was celebrating its
100th year anniversary.
And as a part of that celebration,
they put out a call to the field
to researchers and scholars
to ask if they would take on the challenge
of really reviewing all the
research being conducted
in these different areas of education
over that 100 year period.
So together with my
friend, Susan Brookhart,
we put together an amazing team
of really important scholars
that had looked into the grading area
and asked them to take on that challenge.
And we developed our paper,
which was published in Review
of Education and Research,
and then actually extended that
into the practical vocations
of that work and a book we did for ASCD
called What We Know about Grading,
but what surprised us most
in getting into this area
was to discover how much we
know, how long we've known it
and how little of that has found its way
into practice today.
I mean, I've grown absolutely convinced
there's just not another
area in all of education
where the gap between our
knowledge base and our practice
is greater than in the area of grading.
And so we've got an
amazing knowledge base.
It gives us guidance
on how to do this well.
It's just that we are
so bombed by tradition
that it's very difficult to
challenge those traditions
and implement change in this area.
That is so sort of conformed
in our practices in the past
that it's hard to break.
- So what are some of those things
that you would do differently
or that we need to change
in how we're thinking about grading?
- Well, there are three
things in particular
that we need to do.
Number one, we really need
to do have educators sit down
and establish the purpose.
Why are we doing this in the first place?
Researchers have asked that question
in studies that they've
conducted and find that
we are all over the place
and why are we're doing
it in the first place?
And that means that there's
great diversity then,
in policies and practices,
because teachers believe they're
doing it for different reasons.
And then when we study parents
or students and ask them
their greatest concerns
about fairness and grading,
the number one problem
that they always identify
is the inconsistency among
teachers in the same school.
The only way to establish that consistency
is to start by defining your purpose.
And so it means that school
leaders need to sit down
with their faculty and really
hash out these differences
and come up with a
consistent, purpose statement
upon which we can all have consensus.
And then we look at our
policies and practices
and see if it aligns with that purpose.
Then second,
we need to recognize that we combine
all these diverse elements
when we grade students.
We've found that there
are three different types
of criteria that teachers
use in grading students.
So we've labeled those,
product, process and progress.
Product criteria are sort
of common in administrations
of learning.
You don't worry about how they get there.
You worry about what they've learned
and what they're able to do.
Process criteria are actually behaviors
that enable learning.
And so if you count homework,
you're grading in terms of process.
If you count class participation,
if you count formative assessments,
all of those are process criteria.
And finally, we have progress.
With progress, you don't worry
so much about where they are,
but how far they've come, how
much improvement they've made.
So it would be possible for a student
to make excellent progress,
but still be achieving below grade level.
Now we know that all three
of those are important.
What gets us into trouble is when teachers
combine all three into a single grade,
because then, the grade is
impossible to interpret.
I mean, she got a high grade.
What does that mean?
Does it mean she learned everything well?
Maybe.
Maybe it just means she tried really hard.
Or if you know where she started,
she's come so far during this time.
And so the second thing,
is we need to move away
from a single grade to multiple grades.
We need to give students multiple grades
to represent these
different types of criteria.
So they'll get an achievement grade
and we can still use that for GPA
and all the kind of
things that are important,
but maybe give a separate
grade for homework
or a separate grade for
class participation.
Now,
although that sounds
like a lot of extra work,
what's amazing is if
you go to other places
around the world, if you
go to Northern Europe
and the Scandinavian countries,
if you go to places in Asia,
if you go to schools in Canada,
they have done it for decades.
We are one of the few
developed nations in the world
that persists in this idea of combining
everything into a single grade.
And when I ask the Canadians,
with whom I worked about
the extra work, they said,
actually, it's easier
than what you silly
people do in the states.
I mean, we collect the
same information as you.
We just don't worry about
combining it at the end.
So all those arguments you
have about weighting things,
we don't do it, we keep it separate.
The teachers love it because
they find it's so much easier
to explain students'
performance in the school
when these things are separate,
they find that kids pay
a lot more attention
to things like homework
and class participation
when it's not disguised
in an overall sort of
conglomerate grade, the
parents like it, 'cause again,
provided that promotes their kids.
College and universities
love it because all grades
are carried over to the transcript.
And so you get a bunch more
interesting, much more,
sort of complete picture of a
stats performance in school.
And third, what we wanna
do is, we need to get down
to fewer grade categories,
we need in particular,
get rid of the percentage grade system.
It's just impossible for us to
get any consistency in grades
with 101 discrete categories
of student performance.
Just doesn't make sense.
And I know a lot of people think,
well, but it's giving you
a fine discrimination,
allows us to finely discriminate
among students' performance.
But what we have to
understand is that's only true
when you have direct measures.
Direct measures are things
like height or weight,
where if I have a fine tuned scale,
then I can measure it more precisely.
But most of what we measure
in school is indirect.
And that means we give
kids a series of tasks
and a series of questions to answer.
And then we infer, from their performance,
what level of achievement that represents.
So we move for indirect.
And when you move to indirect measures,
then 101 levels, just impossible to do
in any meaningful way.
The average amount of
variation among teachers
with a percentage grade system
looking exactly the same
(indistinct) of evidence, is
10 to 15 percentage points.
No, and it's huge.
And so--
- That's huge, yeah.
- Yeah.
To get consistency, we
need to get down to a more,
much more reasonable number of categories
of student performance so we can defend
and we can do much more consistency.
So those three things,
be clear about purpose,
multiple grades, fewer
categories of performance.
- That makes sense.
We have a question from Jorge
Leo on Facebook that says,
what are the assessment implications
of this kind of grading?
What does that reveal and
what we should be doing
in terms of assessment practices?
- Well, it does imply
that if you're going to
actually evaluate or judge
students' performance
in these non-academic areas,
that we have to have a clear
rubric of what that means.
If you choose collaboration,
is one thing you want students
to be able to develop, then number one,
you're going to have
to deal with the parent
who comes to you and says,
you gave my kid at two
in collaboration, how can he get a four?
And we need to be able to say,
this is what level four
collaboration looks like.
This is what an example of
level four collaboration
would be, here is how I would
distinguish between those.
And when many schools are
doing, is after the teachers
determine among these sort
of non-academic factors
they're going to consider,
that they turn the job
of developing rubrics
over to the students.
And the students actually
develop these rubrics
where they say, okay, how
could I show the teachers
that I can be collaborative?
How can I show the teacher
that I'm responsible?
that I accept responsibility
and can be acting in a responsible way?
And what we find is that they
are tremendously talented
in being able to define that,
especially when the teachers
give them some guidance
and direction there.
And so you make a really good point.
We need to be able to
specify that clearly,
it's not something we can
just make some judgment of
and have it be out there, we
need to be able to do that.
Now, when it comes to
these process elements,
there are three different times.
There is, first of all,
what we call these learning enablers.
That's what I described earlier.
And that would include
things like homework,
class participation, effort,
formative assessments in life.
A third area, or a second
area is what we call
the social and emotional learning
skills that would include
things like grit,
perseverance, growth mindset,
all these kind of things that we associate
with social-emotional learning.
And here's the third area.
The third area is just compliance.
The compliance is, did you do
what I told you you had to do?
Now, again, we don't know at this time
among those, what's most
important for students.
We're just starting to study that now.
A new center has been established
at the University of
Chicago to look into this,
Harvard University has
established a center
to look into social-emotional
learning skills.
We do know this, you can't do it all.
And so that means the faculty
again, has to sit down
and decide their priorities.
And among those things, what
they consider most important,
then you have to develop
meaningful rubrics for it.
You have to be able to
communicate that rubric
to all the stakeholders, parents
and students in particular,
and then, make sure that you include that
on your report card in a meaningful way.
And in your purpose statement
that you're going to report
those things separately.
- That absolutely makes sense.
In terms of thinking
about all of the pieces
that need to fall into place.
We are already almost at time.
I wanna do, make the circle
back to mastery learning.
I know you've also have a book,
Implementing Mastery Learning
and what that looks like.
How do these grading
practices and mastery learning
all come together to
make that implementation
of mastery learning happen
through these grading practices?
- Well, it's certainly true.
This new version of our book
on Implementing Mastery Learning
is actually a third edition.
It was my very first
book and Benjamin Bloom
actually wrote the initial
foreword to the book.
And so we're taking those
ideas and adapting them now
to a 21st century format.
And one of the things we
talk about in the book
is the use of technology
within mastery learning,
especially as a sort
of instructional vice,
when you have a, sort of flip classroom
or especially in corrective activities
where teachers have tried their best
to teach particular concept
and skills in one way,
they need other options.
And the availability of
instructional alternatives
through technology now is
so wonderful and so broad
that it gives teachers much more latitude
and much more flexibility
in what they can provide
for students.
So it's trying to interpret
that in the modern context,
in which teachers are now working,
and be able to use these
new tools that we have
in good and productive ways.
So we're hoping that this
book will allow teachers
to take those ideas of all students
(indistinct) excellently.
The practical ways of accomplishing that,
as Benjamin Bloom described,
interpreted in a modern context
and in giving them lots
of ideas and examples
from what successful teachers
who are using mastery learning
have found to work pretty well for them.
- That sounds great.
We definitely, not surprisingly,
feel like technology
can help teachers scale
the kinds of practices
around mastery learning
that, where it's difficult
even for one teacher in
a classroom of 30 to do,
and that technology can
be a tool to help them
scale some of these ideas
to their classroom sizes.
So I look forward to reading more.
- Yeah, absolutely true Kristen.
In fact, that's, I
think, one of the things
that all educators have
learned through the pandemic,
is that, if you were unwilling to consider
the viability of technology
before, now it's a must.
And what that did is it opened the door
to all kind of different possibilities.
It certainly increased the demand
for those kind of services,
but I think it made
educators more sophisticated
in determining quality of those as well.
There's a lot out there on the internet
that is not very good.
And to be able to distinguish those
in terms of the quality programs.
And I think that's the
other thing that, I mean,
I don't mean to be an
advertisement for the Khan Academy,
but I think you have
done a really good job
of looking at equality
control for these things
and really trying to ensure,
through various devices,
that the kind of things
that you put out there
are things that are going to help students
in ways that are meaningful to them.
I think that's a tremendous,
tremendous asset.
- Yeah.
That is fundamentally what we are about.
It is already past time
for us to close up.
Thank you so much for joining
us today and for sharing
your views about mastery
learning and grading
with the audience today.
- Kristen, it's been my
pleasure to be with you.
Thank you for this wonderful honor.
I do appreciate it.
And I hope that we'll have
other conversations again.
- Absolutely.
And thanks to all of you
listening for joining us.
Do stay tuned tomorrow.
We have Chase Nordengren
who will be joining us
from NWEA to talk about
goal setting, motivation
and how to start and
reset learning routines,
which are good things to think
about as we head into summer.
Thank you all and we'll see you next time.